[Music]
dianna fighting does not make you a
human what if I promise to be careful
just a shoot and I am no sharp edges be
careful with mankind Diana
they do not deserve you you've told me
this story
[Music]
what is this place who are you people we
are the bridge to a greater
understanding right what is your mission
well here's the thing you are in more
danger than you think the boys in the
trenches called her doctor poison
millions will die the war would never
end
I'm going mother if you choose to leave
you may never return how will I be a
feisty
when you have to
to the Lord well technically the wars
that way but we got to go this way first
how can a woman fight in this
whoa who's this young woman she's my
and
Diana Princess of Timnath Prince Diana
Prince
if you believe that this war should stop
help me stop it right now
oh oh you will soon find out
[Music]
Wonder Woman rated pg-13 experienced at
an IMAX 3d June 2nd
harder you're stronger Denise Diane
again
Oh
[Music]
never let your guard down
you expect the battle to be fair about
the woman never be fair my uh
name is Captain Steve Trevor pilot
American Expeditionary Forces zero
number eight one four one nine two one
that's all I'm at liberty to assign the
British intelligence what the hell is
this thing
the LA Zoo of Hestia compels you to
reveal the truth that is really odd what
is your mission whoever you are you are
in more danger than you think what is
your mission I'm uh I'm spy I'm a spy a
spy please slow down dad your leader how
could he say that believes that you with
your duty to simply give them a book you
didn't send your Browns you're doing
fine just was no chance of changing his
read it's hairy and he's not going to
allow a negotiation or a surrender the
millions of people he tossed about they
will die we worried anyway you mean you
were lying
you're a spy that's what I do how do I
know you're not lying to me right now I
am taking you to the front well you're
pretty gonna die
terrible idea we're gonna need
reinforcements
Oh yep that's not gonna work
please put the sword down Lana Dinah let
me drive by myself after you sir better
like it why don't I meet you back at the
office
and meanwhile I'll take this for safety
no no I don't think so you gotta put the
sword down Diana please it doesn't go
with the outfit at all put the sword
down first at all huh promise me you
will protect it with your life
yes No you can trust her just hand that
over she owes and the shield dinero no
no whoa we got it they set off is easy
Steve why are we hiding
captain Trevor I believe you have
something that is the property of
general ludendorf that's yeah bad guy
convention give us dr. miles notebook
whatever that thing back
or maybe not
tough luck is there anything else you
want to show me stay here I'll go ahead
[Music]
you
what the surprise
strange unfortunately I have another
matter to attend to
what uh-oh
you will soon find out
[Music]
as magnificent as you are you are still
no match for me hmm we'll see about that
if you never met a man before what about
your father
I had no father I was brought to life by
Sir right the gods made the Amazons who
sought peace to the world and it's what
I'm going to do
well that's neat welcome to jolly ol
London he did
yeah it's not for everybody
stay back or maybe not
who's this woman you will soon find out
Oh yep that's not gonna work please put
the sword down it doesn't go with the
outfit at all
[Music]
Wonder Woman rated pg-13 experienced it
in IMAX 3d June 2nd the gods gave us
many gifts one day you'll know them all
this is where we keep them it's
beautiful
who would wield it only the fiercest
among us even could and that is not you
Diana
you will train her harder whoops the
Nene Amazon before her five times harder
ten times harder never let your guard
down you expect the battles will be fair
until she is better than even you but
she must never know the truth about what
she is
[Music]
[Applause]
what is this place who are you
it is our sacred duty to defend the
world right whoever you are you are in
more danger than you think
be careful Diana no one else will defend
the world then I must welcome to jolly
old London be here yeah it's not for
everybody
or maybe not
is there anything else you want to show
me
[Music]
[Music]
what
I'm dyin of dem Aspira daughter of
Hippolyta in the name of all that is
good we'll wrap up on this one
he's over
[Music]
um yep that's not gonna work please put
the sword down it doesn't go with the
outfit at all we need to stop the war
threat war the war to end all wars I'm
going mother it may never return how
would I be a feisty
Diana you are more dangerous than you
think
or maybe not
thank god you're not damaged rated pg-13
experience at an IMAX 3d I used to want
to save the world
this beautiful place
but the closer you get the more you see
the great darkness within
I learned this the hard way
a long long time ago
what is your mission to stop the war
what war the war to end all wars
weapons far deadlier than you can ever
imagine a wall can be Alice
wherever you are you are in more danger
than you think
cannot stand by while innocent lives are
lost
be careful Diana
who's this woman she's my secretary sir
she's a very good secretary
it is our sacred duty to defend the
world and it's what I'm going to do
[Music]
[Music]
how could a woman possibly fight in this
fight we use our principles although I
am NOT opposed to engaging in a bitter
fisticuffs should the occasion arise
have you never met a man before and what
about your father I had no father I was
brought to life by Zeus
well that's neat
[Music]
tough luck
who's this woman you'll soon find out
Wonder Woman is there anything else you
wanna show me with a pg-13 experience at
an IMAX 3d and war-ravaged the earth the
gods created us
I will fight to those who cannot fight
for themselves
woman what where the pg-13 experience at
an IMAX 3d your man yeah yeah I look huh
you have been my greatest love
be careful Diana
I do not deserve you
[Music]
if you never met a man before but what
about your father I had no father I was
brought to life by Zeus perhaps lead
[Music]
[Music]
I cannot do this
what I do is not up to you
[Music]
it's Etta candy I'm at Steve Trevor's
secretary what is the secretary I go
where he tells me to go when I do what
he tells me to do where I'm from that's
called slavery I really like her
fantastic ladies up for you in - I like
who's this young woman she's my she and
I are
working together sir
Diane princess of Timnath Prince Diana
Prince rated pg-13 experienced at an
IMAX 3d
[Music]